Hardly anyone has raised more
conscientious,
imaginative children than the legendary
mid century children's book editor,
Ursula Nordstrom who brought to life
such multigenerational classics as
Margaret Wise Brands.
Goodnight Moon Ed White's Charlotte's
web,
Shel Silverstein's,
the giving tree,
and Maurice Sendak's where the wild
things are.
During her long tenure at Harper and
row,
Nordstrom was not just an editor to her
authors at her artists,
but their friend.
They're confident,
their therapists,
their greatest champion always.
She stood up against censorship and
constantly bolstered the creative
confidence of these young writers and
artists.
She was a special instrumental and the
life of Maurice Sendak who might not be
who we know him as today without her,
and she,
by the way,
was a beautiful letter writer.
Her letters are collected in a book
called dear genius by the Children's
book historian Leonard Marcus.
And so in one exchange with Sendak,
he wrote to her despairing over having
been commissioned to illustrate the work
of tolstoy and feeling utterly
inadequate to match tolstoy's genius.
And so she wrote to him and said,
you may not be tolstoy.
Tolstoy wasn't sendak either.
You have a vast and beautiful genius.
This emboldens Sendak enormously,
and by the following year,
he was already working on his very own
where the wild things are,
which went on to become one of the most
beloved children's books of all time.
But most of all,
nordstrom defended the world and the
experience of the child against all the
commercial pressures for commodities and
conformity and politely boring
storytelling that dominated children's
books at the time.
And so the most benevolent patron saint
of modern childhood ended up being a gay
woman working at the height of
consumerism and somehow managing to
publish an envision and defend books
that were not forgettable commodities,
but extraordinary masterworks.
That's stood the test of time and moved
and inspired and enchanted generations.